Hi. In this video, I'm going to give you a quick overview of what you can do with the YouTube APIs.
First of all, we all know what YouTube is, right?
Millions of videos uploaded from all around the world at your fingertips.
The YouTube APIs allow you to integrate YouTube into your application.
There are two main APIs:...
...the data API and the player APIs.
The data API is a RESTful API that allows you to do a wide breadth of operations:...
...searching, pulling back user information, uploading videos, creating playlists, and much more.
I'll go over the two most popular use cases, "search" and "upload", and show you some examples.
First up, search.
I'm sure you've all searched for your favorite video on YouTube.com.
Using the API, you can send a query for a search term like you would on the site,...
...and retrieve a feed of results in XML,...
...which you could then display in your application how you want.
Another big operation is upload.
Your users can upload their videos to YouTube through your application.
For example, animoto.com is a slideshow creation site.
Once their users create a slideshow, they have an option to export to YouTube.
They use the API to authorize the user to the YouTube account,...
...and then send the video over.
You can get started with the data API with one of our open source client libraries.
We have them for PHP, Java, .NET, and Python.
They make parsing feeds and handling authentication much easier.
I should also point out that, while we don't have a JavaScript client library,...
...we do offer JSON as an alternative format to XML...
...so you can easily parse responses with JavaScript.
Now, on to the player APIs.
The player APIs give you control over the YouTube - embedded player.
You can issue commands like "stop", "pause", and "play";...
...listen for events, like air events...
...or which state the player is in, and poll status,...
...like how far into the video the user is.
Here's an example of an application that's using the player APIs to sync up this lecture with the slides.
If you wanna do even deeper customizations, use our chromeless player.
It's just a video box with no buttons that you can control with the player APIs.
You can skin the player to match the look and feel of your application, much like in these examples.
For even more examples, check out our app gallery.
And once you've built something, show us by submitting yours.
This has only been a quick overview,...
...but find all the rest of the details on code.google.com,...
...and ask your questions in our forum.